I loaded a Beretta 9-millimeter I put up
to my temple and I pulled the trigger
and the greatest piece that I felt was
when that hammer fell because I knew it
was gonna be over it's only a
microsecond but when you spend day in
and day out suffering a microsecond of
pieces in the time since I'm sitting
here and you obviously know that the gun
didn't go off that happened twice
different ammunition I tried to overdose
once and twice I try to slit my wrists
in America around 22 military veterans
kill themselves every day John served in
Iraq during the Second Gulf War his
experiences left him with post-traumatic
stress disorder or PTSD the mental
suffering has been so great but he was
suicidal for eight years one of the
things we never realized was that a lot
of us would be asked to give our life
for our country not in Iraq not in
Afghanistan but far far from the
battlefield at home alone in the dark
combat takes an emotional toll not only
the things you see not only the things
you do but base house on got mortared
thousands of times in a year there's
guys on my base that never went outside
the wire that are suffering extreme PTSD
just from the constant fear of raining
bombs an estimated eight million
Americans suffer with PTSD and war
veterans are only a fraction of this
number it's a public health disaster
costing billions of dollars to treat
there are treatments available but the
drugs prescribed are only successful in
20% of cases for those who don't respond
to the available treatment there may be
an alternative MDMA the active
ingredient in the party drug ecstasy is
being touted as a miracle cure for PTSD
the FDA has labeled MDMA a breakthrough
treatment and tests of the drug show
that it's highly effective in a recent
study over 60% of patients no longer met
the clinical criteria for PTSD after the
MDMA treatment for John conventional
treatments hadn't worked
he saw the trial as his last hope I'd
never taken any psychedelics I'd never
taken MDMA
I kind of thought it was gonna be like
the matrix we're instantly things we're
gonna get magical is it like gradual
rise and gradual fall it's waves where
you start to notice
sometimes people report a lot of
thoughts and then it kicked in after
about 30-40 minutes
[Music]
did you mention and I remember thinking
to myself I completely get what if
you'll take this now for John the
treatment was a revelation it was
probably the greatest therapeutic
experience I have ever had in my entire
life it disconnects the amygdala that
fear response in the brain that
fight-or-flight and you can talk about
the trauma without having a panic attack
mm-hmm he lost his leg part of him
getting here it was my fault the MDMA
puts the brain in a place where the
therapy can work and people always ask
to describe it describe it the best
description I have come up with is it's
like doing therapy while being hugged by
everyone who loves you in a bathtub full
of puppies licking your face
MDMA was used in psychotherapy in the
1970s but became popular as a party drug
in the 1980s and was made illegal it
wasn't until the early 2000s that the
drug began scientific testing in America
to treat PTSD testing is now at the
final stage of FDA approval where around
three hundred subjects will participate
if this is successful then the drug
could become a medicine Rick Doblin has
been at the forefront of this research
since the 1980s in one of the veterans
that was in our study was John Lu Becky
he served 12 years we give MDMA only
three times one month apart with 12
90-minute non drug psychotherapy
sessions and each of the sessions last
eight hours the current treatments for
PTSD flattened out people's emotions and
they're requiring people to take these
drugs every day for months or years or a
lifetime basically
an estimated 20% of former military
personnel suffered with PTSD in America
alone
the Department of Veteran Affairs spends
about 400 million dollars annually on
treating PTSD and other mental health
conditions when you take MDMA it floods
the brain with hormones and
neurotransmitters that evoke feelings of
trust and well-being researchers say
this allows patients to re-examine
traumatic memories all the Bears
like any drug MDMA has side effects and
there's a moderate risk of addiction but
it is less harmful than alcohol or
tobacco small nonprofit is funding the
trial as MDMA is not patentable so big
pharmaceutical companies have steered
clear of the treatment as it will not
make them money for sufferers of PTSD
this new treatment could be a lifesaver
if I hadn't gone through this I'd be an
island so Cemetery
I have a stepson and then if it weren't
for this treatment probably would have
been handed the flag off my casket and
somebody would have had to explain to
him why especially knowing that
treatments are available they made it so
that my stepson will get the flag off my
casket when he's old and gray and I'm
old and gray and after I've watched him
fall in love and graduate high school
college get married bounce a grandchild
on my knee those are the things that
this treatment provides for veterans and
everyone rather than a life cut short
[Music]
you